I don't think that living in the moment
is incompatible with being a long-term
thinker so I think you can live in the
moment and enjoy the present moment but
it's also a way of understanding that
you exist in time right that and that
this this moment is transforming and
that we are constantly constantly in
change I think the difference the the
sort of lousy place that I find were in
a lot in our culture right now is in
constant anticipation of the immediate
next moment which I think it's very
different than being sort of mindful
present enjoying seizing the day I think
it's more like this anticipation of what
you're about to get or what about what's
about to happen and that I think is the
place where we are anxious and where we
are neither in president or future